[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance if you are still waiting for
something about Puerto Rico to bring out
the president in Trump stop there is no
president there if you are still waiting
for something about Puerto Rico to bring
out the American in Trump stop there is
no American there if you are still
waiting for something about Puerto Rico
to bring out the humanity in Trump stop
there is no human beings there over the
weekend during his abusive raging
panicked paranoid tweet storms the
disaster in Puerto Rico cease to be
entirely about the wretched conditions
in a part of the country that is home to
more Americans than every one of our
cities except New York and Los Angeles
it was transformed from mere failure he
transformed it from mere failure from a
question of how far short of success
Trump's response has been and what the
ultimate death toll nightmare will be
even what the ultimate death toll
nightmare of those who survived the
storm but not the criminal neglect of
the quote president unquote will be it
has also now become in horrifying and
revelatory and disqualifying terms about
this creatures damaged mind and empty
soul Trump has previously shown a lack
of human empathy or even understanding
he insulted the City of London and it's
mayors and its victims after a terrorist
attack
he attacked the physical issues of a
reporter he has attacked minority groups
and nationalities and equated the
victims of racism with their attackers
he has attacked and mocked and
reportedly still attacks and mocks a
gravely ill senator to whose party Trump
nominally belongs but Trump's response
following the hurricane damage in
Florida and Texas did not make the
situation much worse there thus there
seemed to be some hope that if it was
still too much to expect that any crisis
or problem could drag him away from his
humble brags and his seeming dedication
to gazing into a mirror 24/7 he at least
had leveled off about not piling insult
atop injury so there was something still
holding many people back from
acknowledging that this man's heart does
not work that is gone now the dead
the dying the displaced of Puerto Rico
are now evidently to Trump quote
politically motivated ingrates the mayor
of San Juan who was out wading through
wastewater searching for victims and
assessing damage while Trump was playing
golf and tweeting was to trump guilty of
quote
such poor leadership ability those in
Puerto Rico who criticized him quote are
not able to get their workers to help
they want everything to be done for them
there are conspiracies everywhere the
mayor of San Juan who was very
complimentary only a few days ago has
now been told by the Democrats that you
must be nasty to Trump despite the fake
news media in conjunction with the Dems
fake news critics are working overtime
the fake news networks are working
overtime in Puerto Rico fake news CNN
and NBC are going out of their way to
disparage our great first responders
because of fake news my people are not
getting the credit they deserve for
doing a great job you don't have to have
a psychology degree to translate the
last one my people he wrote the
President of the United States is
supposed to be saying that about
Americans in harm's way
in this case the Americans on the ground
in Puerto Rico the ones without
electricity or without running water or
without roads or without everything the
Puerto Ricans are not Donald Trump's
people only the first responders are and
what matters is their quote not getting
the credit they deserve which also
obviously translates into something else
namely I'm not getting the credit I
deserve if it could get worse and face
it this is the only Trump skill we must
acknowledge this is a man who can always
be depended on to make a bad situation
fatal it is that this inappropriate
horrifyingly badly timed disgusting
amoral attack on a besieged part of
America and those of its leaders who
have not thanked almighty Trump for not
letting them all die it has to some
degree mask an even grimmer attack Trump
had already unleashed on this tragic
island an attack he has given no
indication that he does not intend to go
through with September 25th Puerto Rico
which was all
suffering from broken infrastructure and
massive debt is in deep trouble
it's old electrical grid which was in
terrible shape was devastated much of
the island was destroyed with billions
of dollars owed to Wall Street and the
banks which sadly must be dealt with got
the message yet Puerto Rico September
29th the fact is that Puerto Rico has
been destroyed by two hurricanes big
decisions will have to be made as to the
cost of its rebuilding Trump is
apparently laying the groundwork for not
spending federal funds on the
reconstruction of Puerto Rico for not
spending money to help afflicted
American citizens some who have lost
loved ones some who have lost home some
who have lost everything
Trump is laying the groundwork for not
helping them fully until and unless they
pay up billions of dollars owed to Wall
Street and the banks which sadly must be
dealt with what do you think that means
that means that the money Wall Street's
money the bank's money is more important
to Trump than the lives of the Americans
in Puerto Rico that he swore an oath to
protect this is who he is money all
there is in life to Donald Trump is
money he did not sell his soul for it
there was no soul to begin with but amid
the wreckage of Puerto Rico and his
churlish small egomaniacal responses to
the criticism of his attention to
himself and not the victims hiding
behind enough about how hurricane Murray
affected me what do you think about how
it affected me is something truly
monstrous Trump seems more concerned
about the money that the overmatched
government of Puerto Rico owes Wall
Street and the bank's then he is about
the Americans who live there he has been
slow to save our fellow citizens how
slow we can debate but it's what he has
planned for them next that should make
every American recoil in horror and
realize that if he could do this after a
natural disaster in Puerto Rico he could
do it in California or Chicago or New
York or Raleigh North Carolina
were Bloomington Indiana or anywhere
that he thinks isn't sufficiently
thankful for him or didn't sufficiently
vote for him sorry about all the damage
Puerto Rico now about your bill because
of fake news my people are not getting
the credit they deserve for doing a
great job his people not the people of
Puerto Rico but the people of Wall
Street and the banks and his god money
and the three million four hundred
eleven thousand people of Puerto Rico
they get to share a golf trophy resist
remove peace my book based on more than
one hundred to these commentaries will
be available presently there will also
be an audio version it will be about
twenty hours long